my brain doesn't work most of the time
and i can't describe it any better than
that like
the things i used to love doing i can't
do anymore because i don't remember how
i so badly want to be who i was
post pre-covered and i tried to be that
person and it just
it's just not there rebecca meyer is one
of thousands of coronavirus survivors
who are plagued with long-term cognitive
health issues associated with cobit 19.
what's really concerning is the vast
spectrum of symptoms that fluctuate
over time even neurological and
psychological effects the severity of
these issues and how long they last is
still unclear
but that's starting to change new
research shows that the coronavirus may
have more wide-ranging effects on the
brain than previously thought
[Music]
we know that it affects the brain
because of some of the symptoms that the
patients are reporting they're reporting
memory issues or the reporting
forgetfulness
the reporting some brain fog they're
reporting some anxiety
some depression doctors say some
patients are also
experiencing inattention and symptoms
that resemble chronic fatigue
syndrome and that many are reporting
them months after initially getting sick
patients that oftentimes are in their
20s 30s 40s never had these symptoms
before or if they did
they were mild this isn't the first time
researchers have seen this
other viral outbreaks like sars mers
ebola
h1n1 and the spanish flu have also
caused
long-term symptoms related to the
nervous system we know that from
sars there were long-term cognitive
changes
there are 50 or 100 patients that that
were
able to be followed up and we saw
long-term neuropsychiatric changes
changes in levels of post-exertional
fatigue
levels of depression and anxiety levels
of
ability to go back to work long-term
covet-19 research
is still in its early stages and right
now
scientists still aren't sure how the
coronavirus affects neurological
functioning
in certain infections viruses can
actually enter the brain
if the brain's immune system reacts that
can lead to swelling
also known as encephalitis while this
can happen with the coronavirus
researchers say it's very rare instead
it's more likely that the virus does its
damage
through an overactive immune response
throughout the body
this can also lead to inflammation which
can harm neurons
cells that are essential to cognitive
functioning here's a closer
look at how that happens the virus that
causes coping 19
usually enters the body through the nose
mouth or eyes
from there it can infect the respiratory
system traveling down the trachea to the
lungs where it can enter the bloodstream
to fight off this infection the body
sends a flood of immune system cells and
molecules
known as cytokines these cause
inflammation which can make it easier
for blood
to form clots when these clots build up
they can prevent oxygen from reaching
vital organs
including the brain which can cause
cells to die in the most severe cases
this can lead to strokes but it's not
just the lack of oxygen that can cause
damage
inflammation can also harm the
protective barrier that shields the
brain
making the organ more vulnerable the
brain
is protected by something we call the
blood-brain barrier and the blood-brain
barrier
is not really a physical barrier but
it's a biochemical barrier and it allows
certain things to go in cells can go in
and out
certain nutrients can go in and out the
blood-brain barrier does a good job at
preventing toxins and pathogens from
entering the brain
but new research shows that the
coronavirus can infect
and disrupt the cells that line the
barrier walls this
is called the endothelium this
disruption causes the body's immune
system to kick further into overdrive
leading to inflammation in the brain
imagine a road
that is paved by endothelial cells
and along that road you have immune
cells like
cars that are rolling along that road
and if a virus or something comes along
and destroys that road the lining the
endothelial cells and it becomes rough
and difficult to ride along
and the immunes now start bumping along
they become activated and they now start
producing
all sorts of free radicals and
inflammatory factors
that repair process if it goes on too
long
you now have ongoing chronic
inflammation we suspect that that is
what happens in the ongoing process
of lung collars and this isn't the only
way that inflammation can attack the
nervous system
cells supporting the olfactory neurons
in the nose
can also be damaged by the infection
scientists suspect that when these cells
die
patients might experience a loss of
taste and smell
research from other infections shows
that inflammatory signals can make their
way up nerves
into the brain causing even more
inflammation these are some of the ways
that scientists think inflammation can
affect the nervous system
and they could explain why so many
long-haul patients are experiencing
neurological problems
so what does this mean for those with
persistent symptoms past epidemics offer
some clues
researchers studying the 1918 spanish
flu found that a number of survivors
showed symptoms related to parkinson's
decades later
more recently physicians have reported
tremors in a few covet 19 patients
but much of the research is still in
animals it may range from some
effects that are temporary to some that
may
be permanent including loss of certain
circuits that may not come back and
those may be associated with
things like dementia or motor symptoms
things like parkinsonism things like
alzheimer's and other dementias
but this idea is preliminary it's a
prediction
based on past events where we know that
viruses that affect the brain directly
or indirectly
may have effects and so we'll have to
see it'll be a matter of time in in
in trying to uh to test it even so
scientists say these findings are an
important step forward
and that the research could help find
answers not just for covid19 patients
but for those with other brain diseases
too one reason to hope
is that i also have seen patients who
have recovered
within weeks to months people who
may have responded well to some
treatment for some
underlying associated brain fog symptoms
it seems that the underlying cognitive
dysfunction has been improving
without any strong you know
immunomodulary
modulatory drugs for example that said
the jury is still out hopefully these
issues that i'm having in other people
it's not
life long that's what we're hoping um it
feels like it is right now
it feels like we're gonna be sick
forever but we just have to
hope that that's not the case
[Music]
you